merci la parole thomas lam bérengère
poletti pour le groupe l'est républicain
merci madame la présidente que chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre
ils sont plus de 3 millions d'actifs
partout sur le territoire
il travaille beaucoup et sont dans la
souffrance il se revendique être la
première entreprise de france
les artisans sont en difficulté et leur
activité encore reculé de 1,5 pour cent
au troisième trimestre selon une étude
récente
monsieur le premier ministre la
situation de ces petites entreprises
continuent de se dégrader
vous n'avez eu de cesse d'augmenter
leurs cotisations sociales et leurs
contraintes
alors que le fsi attend toujours une
véritable réforme
au lieu d'aller vers une amélioration
les relations entre les récits et
cotisants continue de se dégrader double
appel pour les mêmes cotisations non
prise en cause de leurs difficultés
conjoncturelles instruction des dossiers
toujours très longue
tout cela donne aux artisans une
sensation immense d'insécurité et
d'abandon des pouvoirs publics
de plus la couverture dont il bénéficie
est très loin d'être à la mesure de leur
conteneur cotisations petiteretraite
délai de carence en cas de maladie à
sept jours
exclusion de l'indemnisation du chômage
il se demande parfois s'ils sont bien
des français comme les autres
à cela s'ajoute une fiscalité locale
défavorable qui les inquiète davantage
lugo davantage aujourd'hui du fait de la
baisse drastique des dotations aux
collectivités territoriales ils sont
pris dans un effet de ciseaux entre les
hausses de charges et leur difficulté à
trouver des marchés
évidemment l'augmentation de leur impôt
sur le revenu et encore dernièrement le
recul de la mise en place de la deuxième
étape du pack de responsabilité porte un
coup fatal au peu de confiance qui leur
restait en vous alors monsieur le
premier ministre
qu allez vous enfin faire pour soutenir
cette filière professionnelle merci même
pretty la parole est à mme à la main et
seul tour
non ministère social de santé et droits
des femmes merci madame la présidente
mesdames et messieurs les députés
madame la députée ponétie je vous
chercher du regard excusez moi vous
évoquer la situation du rsi mais moi je
voudrais vous dire de la façon la plus
simple et la plus directe qui soit
madame la députée nous nous ne nous
défilons pas nous assumons nos
responsabilités après la réforme
catastrophique qui a été mise en place
en 2008 et qui a provoqué un véritable
accident industriel et nous nous en
gérons les conséquences nous en gérons
les conséquences depuis 2012 d'abord
nous avons mis en place comme je lé
indiqué il y a un instant en répondant à
monsieur chat luz nous mettons en place
des dispositions pour faire en sorte que
le temps qui sépare les prélèvements des
revenus de la perception des revenus
soit limitée au maximum cela a permis à
un certain nombre des artisans qui
connaissent est assurément des
situations très difficile de pouvoir
sortir la tête de l'eau mais ça n'a pas
été suffisant et c'est pour cela que
nous avons demandé à sylviane bulteau et
fabrice verdier un rapport dont nous
avons annoncé un cercle dont nous avons
tiré par dont un certain nombre de
propositions qui ont été annoncées par
christian eckert martine pinville et
moi-même à partir du mois de juin
dernier
nous avons mis en place un certain
nombre de mesure des remboursements de
cotisation plus rapide
un accueil téléphonique de meilleure
qualité nous avons mis en place des
médiateurs pour les cas les plus
difficiles et puis madame la députée moi
je ne peux pas vous dire que nous
laissons aller leur protection sociale
lorsque nous ouvrons par les lois
actuellement en discussion la
possibilité d'acquérir trois trimestres
de retraite par an quels que soient
leurs revenus des taxes des artisans
alors qu'en 2012 il ne pouvait acquérir
qu'un seul
un trimestre de retraite par an vous le
voyez madame la députée nous avançons
nous avançons et la situation des
artisans mérite notre engagement
collectif animaux et mick la parole qu'à
monsieur stéphane demi